we wanted to do a firefly reunion in
honor of by the way
all of us women out there who are
missing our girlfriends
firefly is just such uh firefly
and it's such an amazing celebration of
female friendship
and i was obsessed with the actress who
plays you
as the teenage version of sarah's
character and we invited her here please
welcome rowan curtis
rowan i'm so excited to meet you i was
obsessed with you watching this show
that is the biggest compliment i'm so
excited to be here
well i was obsessed with you both you
both two people
make one whole person and your character
kate
uh you guys learned mannerisms together
and practiced together is that
true yeah um i mean i it's funny i grew
up watching scrubs and so
for me at least like we work together
but for me i feel like
kind of understanding sarah and her
mannerisms was quite
easy for me because i spent so much of
my life watching her
that is helpful and you guys are so
similar on screen but i wanted to see
what both of you guys are like
off screen since i'm such an uber fan of
you on screen
and i was wondering if you guys would
play a game with me called
face the fun facts
okay here's how it works a fact is gonna
go up on the screen
and appear and i've never seen these fun
facts so i'm gonna guess if the fun fact
is about
sarah or rowan and the person who it's
about will reveal herself
and explain the fact sounds great okay
let's see the first fact kicked out of
the choir
in the fifth grade i'm gonna go with
sarah
you would be correct it was mrs mckinney
and it was uh basically singing
christmas carols in a mall not a fancy
choir
and mrs mckinnon said um chalk girl so
she lumped in my sister and i together
could you just mouth the words for this
performance
[Laughter]
i love that i love that story perfect
visual okay the next one
wore matching outfits with mom on
mother's day
i'm going with rowan on this one
you would be correct i um dude
yeah you're two for two um so
it was mother's day and we it was
accidental we just like showed up we met
each other
we didn't even notice that we were
wearing matching outfits and then we
bumped into somebody walking down the
street
and they were like oh you're a matching
outfit and we were like
we are and uh and so then we decided to
take a picture oh that's so
sweet yeah my daughter kicked me in the
shins this morning
okay um who's the truth
um okay next one back
okay can write with her feet
i'm going with sarah
three for three dudes i'm so excited see
this is how i am with my girlfriends i
call them dudes
we um we were in grade
six i think and i was passing notes in
class and getting in trouble
and so then i just wrote the note under
the desk because i i mean you can
imagine have very unattractive long toes
if that's possible
but how like inventive
okay walks a cat outside in a cat pack
i'm going rowan oh yeah um
okay so i got it before we went into
lockdown
and it was kind of like as a joke like i
bought it for myself being like maybe
i'll like take gremlin my cat out for
walks in this like
once or twice and then lock down hits
and i have nothing to do
but take my cat out for walks in
a backpack and now i'm known as the lady
who walks around my neighborhood with a
yellow cat backpack
um all right the last fact is
really good at limbo i'm going sarah
with this one
okay so interestingly enough you
are right and also it's wrong too we
both have this
crazy like it was so weird in the show
we sort of found out we have all these
similar mannerisms and we kind of
both love to dance and have a lot of
similar interests
but we both have our like our secret
kind of superpower is limbo for both of
us
oh oh wow that's low
we got pretty low i honestly i think
sarah was better at it than i was i
think like i
fell i don't know if you can kind of see
it at the end there but i like fall kind
of like onto my
onto all fours and she like kept going
like she was she's on it
yeah i said right you're like full bend
i don't know when i'm gonna learn my
lesson this is something that i love to
do and i've always loved to do but
i have it's turned into a foot ankle
injury situation and i've had to go to
the doctor twice now and they said so
how did you do this and i'm like limbo
again
well you know listen you've got writing
to do with those feet
you've got paddle boarding and crabs to
catch so just take care of that body of
yours
because it seems like you know how to
embrace life and have a good time and i
just want to thank you sarah and rowan
so much for joining me and giving us all
a taste of what it's like to
have the female experience and all the
friendship that goes with
it and so thank you i just am such a
firefly lean fan thank you ladies so
much and of course eat wheaties
will be in theater and demand this
friday april 30th
is when it drops so check
that out and firefly lane if you haven't
already seen it it was number one
on netflix but it's still on netflix so
thank you so much for coming today i
really really appreciate it